Frederick Douglass is my great, great,
great, great,
great, great granddaughter of Frederick Douglass.
I am the great, great,
great, great grandchild.
I've been counting on my fingers since I was, like, five.
Whenever you're ready. Here we go.
This is the fourth of July.
It is the birthday of your national independence
and of your political freedom.
Fellow citizens, I shall not presume to dwell at length
on the associations that cluster about this day.
The simple story of it is that 76 years ago,
the people of this country were British subjects.
Oppression makes a wise man mad.
Your father's were wise men.
And if they did not go mad,
they became restive under this treatment.
With brave men, there's always a remedy for oppression.
They succeeded. And today you reap the fruits of their success.
The freedom gained is yours,
and you therefore may properly celebrate this anniversary.
Fellow citizens, pardon me.
Allow me to ask, why am I called upon to speak here today?
What have I, or those I represent to do with your national independence?
Are the great principles of political freedom and of natural justice
embodied in that declaration of independence extended to us?
I am not included within the pale of this glorious anniversary.
Your high independence only reveals
the immeasurable distance between us.
The blessings in which you this day rejoice are not enjoyed in common.
The rich inheritance of justice,
liberty, prosperity and independence
bequeathed by your fathers is shared By you,
not by me. The sunlight that brought life and healing to you
has brought stripes and death to me.
This fourth of July is yours,
not mine. You may rejoice. I must mourn,
fellow citizens
above your national tumultuous joy.
I hear the mournful whale of millions
at a time like this. Scorching irony.
Not convincing argument is needed.
Oh, had I the ability and could reach the nation's ear,
I would today pour out a fiery stream of biting ridicule,
blasting reproach, withering sarcasm and stern rebuke.
For it is not light that is needed,
but fire. It is not the gentle shower,
the thunder. We need the storm,
the whirlwind and the earthquake.
The feeling of the nation must be quickened.
The conscience of the nation must be roused.
The propriety of the nation must be startled.
The hypocrisy of the nation must be exposed,
and its crimes against god and man must be proclaimed and denounced.
What to the American slave is your fourth of July?
I answer, a day that reveals to him,
more than all other days in the year,
the gross injustice and cruelty to which he is the constant victim.
To him, your Celebration is a sham.
Your boasted liberty and unholy license,
your national greatness, swelling vanity.
Your sounds of rejoicing are empty and heartless.
Your denunciations of tyrants,
brass fronted impudence.
Your shouts of liberty and Equality hollow mockery.
Your prayers and hymns, your sermons and thanksgivings
with all Your religious parade and solemnity are to him mere bombast,
fraud, deception,
impirity, and hypocrisy.
There is not a nation on the earth
guilty of practices more shocking and bloody
than are the people of these United States at this very hour.
Allow me to say in conclusion,
not withstanding the dark picture I have this day presented
of the state of the nation,
I do not despair of this country.
Um,
the speech was written almost 170 years ago,
but there, I mean,
this part of it is still extremely relevant,
especially with today's protest.
I think that when people are oppressed,
they feel silenced, and if someone feels silenced,
they get angry. There are certain tactics that you need to use
to get people to really hear your voice,
and it's not always gonna be just like,
a very calm discussion.
I think he's mostly talking to the people who are already on his side,
but believes that, um,
they can still try to talk this out
or that things are still justifiable.
I know a lot of people at the time were saying,
and people now are still saying,
that it's not as bad as it could be.
While the fourth of July probably does not feel the same to me
as it does to others, I wouldn't say that it has no meeting,
because it's is the time when America
as a country became free from another country.
Um, but I would say that it's not the Time in which I gained my freedom.
He had a lot of hope, especially for his age.
And, like,
I'm getting to the point in my life where I'm only 20 years old,
but I'm exhausted. Like, I'm.
I have these thoughts, like,
will we ever really get to this point?
Or is this really something that we should actually
spend our time fighting for?
Somebody once said that pessimism is a tool of white oppression,
and I think that's true. I think in many ways,
we are still, um,
slaves to the notion that it will never get better.
But I think that there is hope,
um,
and I think it's important that we celebrate black joy and black life.
And we remember that change is possible,
change is probable,
um, and that there's hope.
Haha.